en pratique c'est dans ce lieu que vos
dons pour le téléthon sont utilisés et
c'est ici que tout commence dans cette
pièce la banque d'athènes sont stockés
les échantillons de 83 mille personnes
malades et de leurs familles notre
mission dès le départ c'était de
collecter ces échantillons de l'écho des
de façon anonyme pour être en conformité
avec la cnil pour la traçabilité votre
et après extraire la matière première
pour les chercheurs que il cherche le
mali qui est sûr c'est à terre bonjour
et bienvenue la plateforme d'imagerie
ne vous inquiétez pas au sein de
l'imagerie la lumière était éteinte pour
ne pas détériorer les cellules sur
lesquelles travaillent les chercheurs
grâce à cet équipement de pointe les
spécialistes du généthon peuvent
comparer le comportement des médicaments
appelé vecteur ici en vert par rapport à
la cellule en rouge et voir comment le
médicament est intégré par le patient
grâce à ces études ont ce rendu compte
que les vecteurs utilisés les mécaniques
naturel de la cellule pour s'intégrer
dans le noyau est donc ça permet d'avoir
une étude plus solide et plus poussée
qui permet de comparer les différents
traitements et de justifier des choix
des des vecteurs que l'on en fera pour
soigner les patients grâce à cette
structure inédite
un essai clinique pour le déficit
immunitaire à destination de passion
français anglais ou allemand est en
cours dès 2013 une thérapie génique pour
la neuropathie optique de leber qui rend
aveugle les jeunes adultes va être
lancée et dès 2014 un traitement pour la
myopathie de duchenne devrait voir le
jour des processus étudié depuis des
années en matière de thérapie génique
les chercheurs doivent s'armer de
patience les premiers résultats que nous
avons eu par exemple lorsque nous avons
acquis réussi à guérir la myopathie
n chez les souris c'était en 2005 et là
ça a été une grande avancée parce qu'on
avait réussi à concevoir un médicament
qui déjà chez l'instru marché très bien
et bien c'est en 2014
on va enfin pouvoir le tester chez
l'homme l'afm a été créée en 1990 et est
financé à 90% par les dons du téléthon
plus de 7000 maladies génétiques sont
actuellement connus
un chiffre en augmentation constante
chaque année